okay well welcome everybody looks like
there are still a couple more seats I
see one two three four five and a couple
in the middle on this side but thanks so
much for coming out and joining me today
where we'll be talking about correcting
common mistakes when using async and
await in dotnet my name is Brandon
Minich I work as a developer advocate at
Microsoft and on the bottom of the slide
so that you'll notice a couple links on
the bottom right this is a web page I
put together just for us just for today
this is where you can go to find all the
things that we're going to discuss so
this is where you can find the slides
we're gonna do some live coding demos
they're all open source got them all
linked to there and if you want to keep
going down the async/await
rabbit hole I've also linked a bunch of
articles there that I used when I was
learning more about async and await so
highly recommend checking those out
because it's a pretty complex topic so
this is a subject that's near and dear
to my heart and I say that because
everything we're going over today are
actual mistakes that I've made in my
apps
I am a mobile developer by trade I like
to make iOS and Android apps in c-sharp
using xamarin and I just remember
getting back these the weirdest stack
traces the rudest weirdest crash reports
from my users after publishing my first
app and it was things like exceptions
that shouldn't have been happening
or my app was somehow getting into a
weird state that when I compared the
stack trace to the code I'm looking at
him going there's no way the app can
ever get into that state because the
code shouldn't allow it like what is
happening and it really wasn't until I
started kind of pulling back the covers
on async and await to see how exactly
the compiler handles async and wait
how's it really working under the hood
until I realize like wow okay I'm I'm
making a lot of mistakes so thanks for
joining me today I wanted to share those
with you and let's kick it off just by
talking about multi-threading so a
thread think of it just as a chunk of
code so
threat basically just contains a chunk
of code that's going to go through a CPU
and the CPU will execute whatever it
tells it to do so it could be a couple
methods or functions but we can have
multiple threads with multiple chunks of
code and nowadays with multi-core
processors if you have say a four CPU or
a four core CPU well that means you can
have four threads going through each
core simultaneously so multi-threading
means you have code that can run
simultaneously it can also be that you
have threads dependent on other threads
like maybe they're waiting for a long
background task to finish and with.net
we are really fortunate because we have
this thing called the thread pool it
hasn't always been there if anybody was
around back in like the dotnet one days
you had to manage threads on your own I
mean nowadays we don't really have to
worry about that but yeah back in the
day you had to create your own threads
you had to dispose your own threads you
had to keep track of all the different
threads that are running you had to
figure out how many threads you could
have but yeah nowadays we are super
fortunate in net that we have the manage
thread pool so the manage thread pool is
basically where all these will say
basically all the background threads
live and it is orchestrated by this
thing called the synchronization context
the synchronization contexts think of it
like a conductor up in front of an
orchestra so it's what queues this
thread to start and then when that
threads finish it'll grab this thread
and tell that to start and just make
sure everything's happening in the
proper order and with the thread pool
there is a limit on the number of
threads on each device now that that
limit is actually dependent on that
devices virtual memory again we don't
really need to worry about too much
about this but it's kind of cool to know
that the same chunk of code let's say
you wrote block of code and c-sharp that
can run on an IOT device well that's
gonna have less threads available to it
than that same chunk of code if we were
to run it on say a server with 64 gigs
of RAM but again if we start consuming
all the threads I mean that's not right
we should probably fix that code but if
it does happen thread pool just queues
up
tasks and whenever a thread is free it
handles it for us so super fortunate to
have this in.net
and let's take a look at some actual
code here to see what it's what's
actually going on and so this is this is
a pretty simple method it's called read
data from URL we pass in a string we
knew up a web client we called download
data task async which we are awaiting
and then that returns a byte array we
turn that byte array into a string we're
at a different method called load data
and if you're already thinking why isn't
this guy using HTTP client you're
totally right this is just this is kind
of an old example but I wanted to keep
it simple
so yeah in your code make sure to use
HTTP client but just for the sake of
simplicity let's check this out so with
with three data from URL let's say
thread one kicks off this method so
thread one comes into here at News up
web client it initializes this byte
array and then when it gets to that
await keyword download data task async
is run on a different thread now for the
safety for the sake of this example I've
called it thread two but it could be any
thread the synchronization context will
just literally bill look at the thread
pool say what thread is available and if
thread five for a thread 17 or thread 32
is available it'll just grab it and run
the code on it so but yeah so let's say
download day to task async is running on
thread two now and because we called
that a weight keyword thread one is free
to go back and do whatever and this is
huge
this is this is really important because
if thread one was running this that's
bad in any in any UI based application
so web apps mobile apps desktop apps
thread one is what we call the UI thread
it is also known as the main thread it's
also what paints everything onto the
screen so anything that appears on the
screen that has to be done on thread one
so main thread UI thread I'll probably
use those terms interchangeably today
but if thread one was running download
data task async and
let's say download data task a sync
takes 10 seconds well that would have
meant thread 1 would have been locked
for 10 seconds so what's that look like
to our users well they just see a frozen
app they try to scroll they try to swipe
they're trying to click a button nothing
happens and then what right they they
forced quit the app or they closed the
webpage they give us a one-star review
they tweet out about how garbage our app
is but with a Sega wait we call that a
wait keyword and that frees up thread 1
so thread 1 is free to interact with the
user meanwhile thread 2 in the
background is running download a to task
async so when thread two's done it goes
back to the synchronization context and
says hey I'm all done synchronization
context says great which thread called
you and it goes thread 1 called me so
what happens well the synchronization
context says thread 1 your backup and
thread 1 jumps back into this method and
finishes it off it continues to do the
string conversion and run that method
called load data so not too bad I think
most of us in here probably have
experienced that before but what's
really happening to understand that we
need to go a little deeper we need to go
look at the compiled code so here's that
same method again but here's what it
looks like with the compiler generated
code now the first thing I want to point
out is that this is a class it's a class
that inherits from I a sync state
machine now I didn't write a class I
wrote an async task method but what the
compiler does every time we use that
async keyword it converts our method
into a class but I mean no big deal it
does that does add about a hundred bytes
of overhead to our final app size but
you know it's 2019
what's a hundred bytes I mean unless
you're doing something on a small IOT
board hundred bytes per async methods
probably not going to kill you but it
does it turns into a class and all those
local variables that we had in our class
now become
fields and the variable names look a
little different but we can still see
there's private string data private byte
array result web client WC and the URL
since it was a parameter that stays
public and the only difference is you
see some angle brackets and some ungar's
underscores this is just something that
the compiler does for us because it
needs to make sure that the variables it
creates are unique and you know it's
never gonna know what what we named our
variable so it slapped some angle
brackets on it it slap some numbers on
it just to make sure those variable
names in the compiled code stay unique
now probably most importantly is this
move next method if you've ever gotten a
stack trace back from an async method
chances are you've seen move next I know
I have and I had no idea what it meant I
kept seeing these stack traces come back
and I was like move next I never wrote a
method called move next like where's
this code even coming from well turns
out that's part of this compiler
generated method that's part of I a sync
state machine and here is what move next
looks like it's just a giant switch
statement and what we end up with we
have a case for every single time we
call the away keyword plus one so in
this case or in this instant instance we
have two cases in our switch statement
because we called the away keyword once
if we use the awake keyword four times
we would have five cases in the switch
statement but if we take a look at those
cases starting with case zero this is
just our code and we can see here that's
newing up the web client kicking off
download data task async and then thread
1 returns so this is how thread 1 is
freed up
it literally exits this method it's done
that's how it's going back to interact
with the user and handle the scrolling
and the tapping but before it returns it
sets that value of PC to 1
and it does that because when thread
two's done with download data's ask a
sync and the synchronization contacts
comes back and says hey thread one your
backup thread one jumps back in picks up
where it left off in two case one and
that's where it gets the results from
download data task async that's where it
converts that byte array into a string
and then runs that method called load
data so pretty cool this is something I
was impressed by when I when I first saw
this cuz think about what has happened
dot nets a framework that existed before
multi-threading was really a thing
existed before really like multi-core
CPUs were even a thing and the smart
folks on the.net team figured out how to
give us just a basically two keywords
async and weight and then they'd handle
all this stuff behind the scenes
building out this state machine and
making sure everything works properly
and all we have to do in our code is
just slap async await on it and it just
works
now this is what got me I did not see
this coming
move next is entirely wrapped in a
try-catch block now I didn't write a
try-catch block in my code but when the
compiler generates this code and
generates move next by default it wraps
everything into a try-catch block so
what's this mean well it means that any
exception that happens in my async task
method that exceptions caught right here
now don't worry too much because that
exception gets three thrown as long as
we use the awake keyword but if we don't
use the awake keyword if we do what I
like to call a fire-and-forget task
where you know maybe we say task dot run
we put a block of code in there we say I
don't care when it finishes just go
ahead and do your thing well if we
didn't await that task and it threw an
exception in that block of code that
exception swallowed up and it's gone
forever so you might be thinking that's
a good thing right like exceptions suck
they crash your app I'd rather have no
exceptions I'd rather wrap everything in
a try-catch block but over the years of
coding I've kind of come to learn is
like I want exceptions exceptions tell
me when something's wrong and when I
know something's wrong I can handle it
gracefully and this is really what was
getting my app in a weird state was I
was doing those fire-and-forget tasks
I'm saying cast out run go not awaiting
it that was throwing an exception and
now my code is in this state that it
shouldn't be in all because an exception
got thrown and I never knew about it so
always make sure to await those async
task methods all right quick review the
async keyword has about a hundred bytes
and that's just because every async
method becomes a class now hundred bytes
maybe that means something to you maybe
it's it doesn't but it's good to know
it'll increase your app size by just a
little bit and then like we just
discussed
make sure to await every task because
non awaited tasks hide exceptions we
want to make sure we throw those
exceptions or we're Heather rethread the
exceptions by using that await keyword
okay so now that we are async await
expert so let's jump into some code and
fix it up so behind me I have I have an
app that I made to read hacker news if
you've never heard of hacker news it's
just a really cool website where a lot
of tech news gets posted and so since
it's one of my favorites I figured why
not make a quick app this is an app that
works on iOS and Android and made in
c-sharp using xamarin and it'll go out
we'll get the top stories from hacker
news and I can click on any of these
stories and give them a read in that way
now I don't have to launch my web
browser to learn about probably got
slack getting a 16 billion dollar
valuation that's impressive
good for them but anyways the code
behind me um I will say don't worry
about memorizing anything we're doing
today I say that because we're gonna be
working in this view model called bad
Aysen
can await practices but there's another
view model called good async and way
practices so yes the codes all open
source if you want to go back share it
with your friends show your co-workers
you can just compare the bad and the
good because the good has everything
done that we're about to do and fix in
this bad async/await practices view
model and I'll make sure to give you a
chance to grab that link again and
that's where you'll be able to find the
code ok so the first to do right here we
have method this is a async task method
that is actually a task of type bool it
returns and we're calling dot wait now
this is bad I have a rule of thumb and
it goes saying never never never never
never never use that wait don't use it I
had it's a code smell I wish it was
never even put into the dotnet framework
I actually reached out to the team at
one point I was like can we just
deprecated this and like now it's got to
stay don't use it why is that way bad
well dot wait says let's say let's say
thread one kicks off this method so
thread one gets to hear it hit set is
refreshing dot wait and out wait says
hey thread one you stay right here
you're locked don't go back and interact
with the user I'm hanging on to you
meanwhile it's grabbing a background
thread to actually execute set is
refreshing so we we have thread one
locked and that's bad because now we can
update the screen we can't interact with
the user but we're also having another
thread run set is refreshing and setting
that to true and so not only is our app
frozen but we're using two threads when
we only should be using what so easy fix
whoops there we go so easy fix get rid
of dot wait and just use the away
keyword now I I will say it's getting
it's getting rare nowadays but sometimes
we still do need to use or write
synchronous code I mean we're we're
fortunate here where we are in an ace
method but maybe you know that one
percent of the time we still have to
write synchronous code so you're
probably thinking yourself well wait a
minute
what do we do because you just said
don't use dot wait well there's a better
way to do this
whoops get resolved there we go
and that's to use get await or get
result now get away or get results still
isn't great it does the same thing is
that wait it'll still lock the calling
thread it'll still run that method on a
background thread so we're using two
threads when we only need one and also
locking that thread if it's the UI
thread mmm well now our apps frozen but
why get a get it later get resolved is
better it's because dot wait well we'll
say if if this method throws an
exception just like the await keyword ah
wait will wreath row that exception but
it doesn't read through our exception it
wreath rows what's called a aggregate
exception so system tagra gate exception
and that is an exception that holds
exceptions
it's like exception inception where our
stack trace and our code is somewhere in
that aggregate exception but it's not on
the top level what get away or get
result does is actually it throws our
exception with our code and our stack
trace so instead of instead of getting a
aggregate exception and having to dig
through that to try and figure out where
our code is or if you have new
developers on your team who have never
seen an aggregate exception before
that'll just confuse the heck out of
them get a weight or get result well we
throw your exception and your stack
trace so well it's better than dot
weight but again we don't want to use
two threads we only need one we
definitely want to lock up the UI thread
so we'll just use the awake keyword done
and down here same same we have another
dot weight so this is an easy fix we
just slap the awake keyword on there and
we're good to go and yes you can use the
awake keyword in the finally block so
kind of cool that wasn't originally
baked into async/await but they gave it
to us Avenged
next refactor so we have another method
here this one's called get top stories
this is what goes out hits the hacker
news api's brings back what's it do
first it brings back all the IDS and
then once you have the IDS you can get
the stories and then we add them to our
top story list and we return that so
this one's not using dot wait it's using
the await keywords so that's pretty good
what can we do to make this better well
let's think back to that example we saw
in the slide so let's say we'll say
thread one kicks off this method so
thread one initializes top story list
thread one initializes the variable top
story IDs we hit the await keywords so
thread one's free well the background
thread runs get top story IDs so let's
say thread five is gonna is going to run
get top story IDs
well when thread five is done what's it
do it goes to the synchronization
context synchronization context says oh
good you're all done what thread called
you it says thread one called me and
then thread one jumps back in and
continues writing this code so kicking
off this four loop here now that's not
terrible but why did we have to go back
to thread one I mean especially since
thread one is our UI thread we want to
leave that free we don't we barely want
to use that for anything except UI stuff
or user interactions and here we are
bringing it back into our view model and
in the mvvm world like view models don't
touch UI so we don't need it Plus what
happens if thread one is busy like maybe
the users just scroll on the screen or
jamming buttons or maybe we have a game
that needs to run at 60 frames a second
well our code is just sitting here
waiting until thread one's available to
jump back in so we could make this a
little bit better a little bit faster by
using configure await false
so what configure await false does win
so in this example when thread five is
done and get top story IDs is finished
executing thread five now with configure
wait false ghost the synchronization
context
synchronization contact says great
you're done which thread called you and
thread five just goes doesn't matter
and so the synchronization contact just
grabs whatever threads available and
that thread will continue running our
code so a thread seventeen can jump in
and kick off the rest of the method so
my rule of thumb is if I'm in the
service layer of my app or being that I
do a lot of mvvm if I'm in the view
model layer of my app anything that
doesn't touch UI code that I don't
really care what thread I return to I
put configure await false everywhere
pretty much the only place I don't use
configure away false is if I'm in the
viewer I'm interacting with the UI now
you might be wondering yes that says
false so there must be a true and if you
spell it right there we go what is that
- well that's just the default so by not
putting anything like if we didn't have
this here that's the same as configure
away true so you'll probably never do
this but like I said if you don't need
to return back to the calling thread
configure await false
all right so refactor done and we've got
another one here same story slap on a
configure await false and refactor done
cool making progress all right next up
we have a method called get story get
story calls a method called
get data object from API so this is just
hitting the hacker news API and pulling
down the story and it looks pretty good
right like we're using a wait we're
using async we could probably put a
configure wait false on there I don't
know if it's already there no it's not
but this is a cool example because if we
take a look at what this methods
returning get data object from API is
returning a task of type story model and
get story is also returning a task of
type story model so what we can do here
we can actually get rid of this async
keyword and get rid of that awake
keyword
and we can just return the task now it
feels a little weird yeah this is
probably something that most of you
haven't seen before I don't see it a lot
in code well I guess except for my code
I love this but by just returning the
task and getting rid of that a weight
keyword we just saved herself to contact
switch so we didn't have to switch from
thread one to thread five or thread two
to thread seven whatever it might be we
can just return the task and allow
whichever chunk of code calls get story
to a weight get story and handle that
contact switch for us and by getting rid
of that async keyword well now the
compiler doesn't turn it into a I a sync
state machine class anymore and so we've
saved you know a hundred bytes in our
app size so yay but the big benefit
there is that performance impacts so we
don't have to we don't call the await
keyword which means we don't switch
context or switch threads and we can
save that switching and our code will
run just that much faster all right so
the next one get top story IDs this is
the first method that runs and hits the
hacker news API and pulls down their IDs
because for whatever reason their API
says you can't read a story unless you
know it's ID first so great we got to
make two calls this is also get data
object for API is also returning a task
of type list of type string and just
like the last method so is get top story
IDs so right we can get rid of that and
get rid of that and this will work it'll
compile it'll run but this is actually a
trick question because we don't want to
do that here this the reason I show this
is because when we return the task that
means we're not waiting for it to finish
we're literally returning right away
we're saying up here's the task it's
still running in the background but here
you go
so because we return right away that
means we've exited the method and if so
fact that we've exited the try-catch
block so if this were to throw an
exception
we've already exited the method
and that exception will never be caught
here so don't do this if you're inside
of a try-catch block make sure to use
return away inside try-catch blocks but
otherwise yeah you can just return the
task now there is something cool I want
to show you with this method here let's
say let's say it's a top storage
what's that method or property gone top
story list so let's say top story list
and let's check first to see if it's
count is greater than zero
and if it is instead of going and
hitting that API again which I find
super annoying why don't we just grab
the IDS we already have so you grab that
ID make sure it's a string and that also
has to be a list basically just why
don't we just return the IDS we already
have yeah how much how much are the top
stories gonna change in the five minutes
that our users are using yep Robin app
not that much so let's make a little bit
more performant but what we've just done
we've created another path in this
method so we have an async task method
that the first time it runs we're going
to come down here and hit this return
away get data object from API but the
second time it runs we're gonna hit this
path and we're not gonna use the await
keyword anywhere we're just going to
return the information we already got
and same with the third time it runs and
the fourth time it runs and so this
right here is what we call the hot path
in our method so if we have a the hot
path in our method that does not use the
away keyword we can use this cool thing
called a value task now value task this
is this is pretty new it's being added
to dotnet standard 2.1 Donnison or two
but one hasn't been released yet but it
is value task is available in a new get
package and I'll share that link with
you in just a bit
but what value task does is basically
the same thing as a task but it's a
value type so
if you think back and remember task is a
reference type reference types live on
the heap value task is a value type and
that lives in the stack now if you
remember all the way back to data
structures classes or if you're been
studying up for an interview coming up
you'll know that it's more expensive to
put something on to a heap than it is to
put something on to a stack because when
you put stuff on to a heap it's got to
be indexed and it's indexed because well
it's really quick to read from the heap
whereas it's a little slower to read
from the stack but in this case we're
not really using all those benefits of
tasks all the time so why take that
performance hit nine times out of ten to
put a task on the heap when we don't
need to and we can use value tasks and
so value tasks living in the stack that
means as soon as this methods done it's
popped up we save a garbage allocation
or a garbage collection and we also save
that memory allocation and so if you
find that spot your code where the hot
path does not use the async keyword I'm
sorry it does not use the awake keyword
checkout value task all right
let's say how we doing cool so back up
to the constructor when this constructor
loads I call execute refresh command
that's the method that we saw earlier
that will hit the api's it'll load all
the data and I have that here my
constructor maybe I shouldn't but I want
my app to load the data as soon as the
app launches I don't want I don't want
to load an empty app for my user and
force them to do a pull to refresh
that's silly so I have it here my
constructor but this is also an async
task method this method returns a task
and we're not awaiting it and that's why
we written that yellow squiggle right
there that's why if Visual Studio is
yelling at us and so I don't know maybe
we can do a sync wait and that's gonna
yell at us and it should because
constructors will never be able to use
async await constructors are just
literally meant to initialize objects
they allocate some memory
maybe they assign some variables and
initial value but they're not supposed
to do anything long-running you should
never have to await a new object so that
that fails can't do that
well something we could do is this and
change that to refresh so now that
squiggle goes away in our constructor
and what we've just done and I can feel
I can feel the cringe going on right now
because we just made an async void
method now I I do have a bone to pick
with async void and that is just how
it's how it's typically taught you know
when we're first learning async and a
weight everybody says if you're gonna
use the async keyword always return to
task
well now that value task is out that's
of cool too but they say never use async
void and that's not bad advice like
async void can be dangerous and I'll
tell you why in just a second but the
problem I have with telling developers
never use async food is they never say
why so so let's check out why and I mean
spoiler alert this is an actually this
is actually a valid use case for async
void we'll say it's one of the few but
it is valid because look we kick off
this method we cannot await it but
inside there we are calling an async
task method and we are awaiting it so if
an exception gets thrown inside of
execute refresh command because we use
that awake keyword that exception will
be wreath round in surface back to us
but what so why is async void dangerous
well let's check this out let's say we
did something like this putting it in a
try-catch block exception let's print
that at the console
and exception so so we know refresh is
going to throw an exception right throws
it right here as soon as it's done with
execute refresh command but that
exception will never be caught in this
catch block and here's why
let's say thread one kicks off our
constructor thread one calls refresh so
thread one comes into here thread one
hits this await and so now executes
refresh command is running on a
background thread let's say it's running
on thread 3 and thread 1 is now coming
back up here but since we cannot await
excuse me since we can not await an
async void thread one just continues
so we'll say thread 1 continues here and
and so now thread once down here
executing some more code meanwhile this
refresh method is technically still
running because XQ refresh command it
takes a couple seconds to do stuff in
the background hit the api's and so when
this exception triggers
we've already exited this catch block so
that's one reason why a sync void
methods are dangerous because you'll
almost never be able to catch an
exception from an async void method now
another reason that's dangerous is let's
say we were doing something with that
top story list right like maybe here we
choose to new it up story model and I
don't know maybe we say add and we dot
dot dot we do some more stuff there so
so thread 1 is now interacting with this
property top story list meanwhile thread
5 is running in the background doing
execute refresh command which also
interacts with top story list and so now
we're gonna see some really weird
behavior because know which one wins we
got this race condition so maybe a
thread one wins and we new up and we add
some stuff but then thread 5 gets there
and adds some more stuff in there weird
things are going to happen here and it's
all because of that async void and
because you cannot
oh wait in a sink void method so the
probably the scariest thing that I've
ever come across when working on working
in some code is when there's been a
public async void method that I didn't
write like big chunk of code co-worker
in another class or in an another
c-sharp file created the class that had
a public async void method on it well I
mean right here we can see it like async
voids right there got it
but let's pretend like it wasn't and
we're just using intellisense right and
Intelli sense let's see if we can zoom
in on that and tell us I just tells us
that refresh returns a void so any
c-sharp developer worth their salt will
Sayed say to themselves and rightfully
so that will refresh this method will
run to completion before it continues on
and execute the rest of these just the
rest of this code but in reality whoops
there we go but in reality it was an
async void method and not you have that
method running at the same time so so
that's why async voids dangerous and why
even though this is a valid
implementation and usage for acing fide
it's still not super recommended because
I mean we can see it right here but what
about a couple years from now new
developers take over the same codebase
they might not know that's an async void
method and they might make the same
mistake that we just did right here and
now they'll be wondering why they're
exceptions not being caught in there try
catch block okay great so what if we
accomplished basically nothing because
we said we didn't want to do that
so back to this well what can we do you
know async Floyd would be perfect if we
could do that but it feels icky and
we're setting up our co-workers for
failure so something I did I created an
extension method called safe
fire-and-forget
so everywhere as saying earlier why
fire-and-forget methods are bad like
when you say test dot run kickoff some
code that you're not awaiting it well
those are bad because your
awaiting it but at the same time you
might not care when that code finishes
so you might not want to say I want to
wait for this I just want to kick it off
but I still want to follow best
practices so this safe fire-and-forget
method let's actually jump into that
this is an async void method it's an
extension on tasks and we've got some
goodies in here like we can pass in we
what we want to do with configure await
so we can still say configure away false
and if we want to we can also pass in an
exception handler but if we don't that
exception will just be wreath rowan so
that's what that means right here so if
on exception remains null that exception
gets wreath rowan and happy days because
that exception was exposed to us
otherwise in the old bad fire-and-forget
way that we just say tasks that run that
exception would be swallowed forever so
so i put this together so that it's
blatantly obvious that you want to fire
and forget this method but you still
want to do it safely you still want to
make sure that exception happens and
then you can take advantage of that in
your code now like i mentioned earlier
all this codes open source so feel free
to download it copy pasted into your
code but I've also nuga ties this so
this is also available as a nougat
package if you just want to slap it into
your app that we'd have to worry about
copy and pasting code around the nougat
package name is called async await best
practices and I'll share that link with
you again just a minute alright so done
there and we've got one more refactor
and let's see refresh command so if
you've ever done anything with with mvvm
you've seen commands all the time if you
haven't don't worry about it maybe
you'll come across at some point but
we're getting yelled at here because
command takes in in action and what's an
action return void so by saying hey sync
void well by saying async we've just
actually just created an async void
method but again this is another valid
use case for async void and this is
totally fine you don't have to change
this at all I mean you get the little
yellow squiggle saying that asynchronous
method should
return void but you just got to go nope
I'm smarter than that this one's
actually cool but if you want to get rid
of that yellow squiggle I've put
together another library called ìa sync
command a sync command a sync man there
we go
and what with this we don't have to say
we don't even have to say async/await we
can just literally pass in that task and
Aysen command actually takes advantage
of say fire-and-forget so if we if we
were to jump into this code this one's a
little bit more verbose but you can see
down here when you execute that command
it's using say fire-and-forget but again
it's nicer because we get rid of that
little squiggle and I async command also
has a couple more extra properties that
I command doesn't so if you do want to
call this command from a different class
you can actually await it whereas normal
I command is typically fire-and-forget
all right
so let's review those best practices we
were just chatting about never use dot
wait never use that result I hate them
their code smells get them out of your
code because we should be using the
await keyword but if in that rare point
that you do have to write synchronous
code both can be replaced with get away
to get result and get away to get result
is will still lock the calling thread
but it's better cuz it'll throw our
exception with our stack trace and our
code whereas dot wait and dot result
both throw an aggregate exception and
yeah it's a good point I forgot to
forgot to show off dot result is also
replaceable so literally get a way to
get result if your task is returning a
type bool get a way to get result will
return that bool if it's just returning
a task it'll just return void so get
away to get result use that to replace
both wait and dot result don't use those
fire-and-forget tasks well say be
judicious how you use these i you should
be awaiting every task but if for
whatever reason you don't really care
when that task finishes you want to kick
it off you want to fire and forget but
you still want to follow all those best
practices and you don't want to add a
sync void methods into your app check
out the safe fire and forget extension
method I've put together and that's the
name of the new get package behind me
and I've included a link to that new get
package on the NGC also async/await site
at the bottom async commands so if
you're doing commands and you want to
get a little bit more flexibility around
making it away table having some async
and weight stuff you can also check out
I a sync command and that's also in a
nougat package so I've put together
called async await best practices dot
mvvm also like below returned await
don't use it if the only place in your
method you're using the await keyword is
in the return statement rip it out get
rid of a wait get rid of async and just
return that task
that'll make sure we don't do an extra
thread switch or context switch
and our code will run just a little bit
faster now again a couple caveats if
you're in a try-catch block keep that
returned await in there otherwise you're
gonna return that task right away you're
gonna exit the try-catch block same if
you're in a using block so if you're
going to dispose an object make sure to
do return a weight because again if you
return the task you'll exit right away
and then all of a sudden that object
that you need it is now disposed and
you'll get weird errors like I did was
if I out of time can figure away false
use it I use this like I said I use this
everywhere every time I'm not touching
code that interacts with my view with my
UI I use configure away false and so the
rule of thumb is if you don't care what
thread you return to use configure away
false there's no reason to wait on a
thread that might be busy and burns
burning CPU cycles just sitting there
waiting for your thread to come back
when you can just grab a perfectly good
thread different thread from the
background pool from the thread pool so
use configure white false whenever you
don't need to return to the calling
thread and lastly value tasks this is
this is new this is hot off the presses
like I mentioned it is coming in dotnet
standard 2.1 but today it's available in
this nougat package system threading
task extensions and I've also linked
that to like that for us in the link at
the bottom of the slides here alright so
speaking of that link if you haven't had
a chance yet make sure to take out your
phones grab a picture of this slide
bookmark it share it with your friends
show with your colleagues because this
is where you can find everything that we
just talked about today this is where
you'll be able to find the slides this
is where you'll be able to find the
source code for the safe fire-and-forget
4i a sync command if you want to check
out that hacker news app if you're into
xamarin apps like I am those are all
linked there the nougat packages are all
linked and then if you want to continue
this journey and I highly recommend it
it's a pretty deep rabbit hole but
there's also a bunch of links that I've
included there on how value tasks works
how a sync void works and you can
continue
studying and reading up and going down
this rabbit hole highly recommended
thank you so it looks like we do have a
couple minutes if every wants to stick
around I know we have a microphone in
the back and we can shoot out some
questions I just I do ask make sure we
get the question in into the microphone
so I saw the first hand over here that
way anybody watching the video later
they'll be able to hear you're asking
questions as well hello thank you very
much for this nice presentation and
thank you my question is simple I'm just
wondering how you do you need testing of
this weight and the sink how you unit
test a sink in a weight yes I mean unit
tests are just c-sharp codes so you can
also use async await keywords in your
unit test that might depend on what
framework you're using I know the one
I'm most familiar with is n unit and
yeah as of n unit 3 you can just
async/await everywhere so yeah if you do
want to weight a method you can do you
can do that and actually that is a cool
question because I've I have unit tests
in that library so for all those those
those two NuGet packages I've made I've
just got a suite full a unit test if you
want to check those out but yeah they're
all use an end unit and you can do
async/await you can do things like
checking the current thread running
something called and configure weight
false then checking the next thread
making sure it's different making sure
it didn't go back to the calling thread
and yep that's all available to you and
unit testing
thank you thanks a good question ok
great
oh I was wondering if you would like to
run let's say two service calls in
parallel we use a way to task when oh
yeah is that a valid place to use get
result or because you after the tasks
have finished you some you know I have
to get the results from both of the
tasks right so yeah just to fill
everybody in what we're saying is let's
say maybe we have task 1 equals and I
will say at a stopped run a sick way uh
no it's not even go that far I was just
a test not to way there we go so get
that I've got that call that task 2 and
then what we can do is say test uh when
all and just for anybody that hasn't
seen tasked out when L before what this
does we what we've done we are we're not
awaiting these tasks here but we are
awaiting them in test out when L so like
you mentioned if you want to kick out
some things in parallel you can start
the task and then await it all together
and this will then continue when both
tasks have finished so like if this one
was a little longer maybe took well took
longer took twice as long this code will
continue when both have finished so yeah
the question was well what if we do get
a waiter no the result here that was
actually not was what I was thinking
about I was thinking about if task 1 and
task to our returning a value of some
sort or our result then you after they
are finished you would like to get the
results yes okay awesome
so yeah let's tweak this a little bit
coating on the fly test that run and
[Music]
we'll just say we'll cheat a little bit
here just alright so so down here we're
saying what if we say get a waiter get
result here right yeah cool so so now
what's happened right we've kicked off
these tasks let's pretend like they're
doing something important and not just
returning true right away they're doing
something important something's gonna
take a while a weight test out win all
will continue once both tasks are done
and now task 1 we know for a fact is
completed and so if we call get await or
get result what happens well if the task
will say tasks tests are kind of smart
if the task is already completed it'll
just return that boolean value so this
will just return true right away we
won't lock up the calling thread we
won't have another thread running in the
background so this this is actually ok
because we're not going to we're not
gonna break anything
that being said just for a best practice
and I know this is gonna look kind of
funny I still do this
there's in this specific example where
we know the task is finished there's
really no benefit to call a weight or
configure a weight false because we're
not gonna switch threads like I
mentioned if the task is already
completed
there's no thread switching there's no
contact switching but the reason I still
await it and throw configure weight
falls on that if you want to it's
because we don't we might not always own
this code maybe a junior developer comes
in later and changes this around and
he's just said away tasks too well
if we still had get a waiter get result
if we still had get away to get result
here well now we're going to have some
trouble this is going to lock up the
calling thread so you can and in that
specific example it's it is safe you're
not gonna get any trouble to use and get
away to get result after a tossed out
when all because you know the task is
done but I always like to think ahead
you know what about that future
developer when they take over the code
so I will still use a wait configure
wait false even though it technically
doesn't do anything at this moment in
time does that make sense yeah questions
between using tasks one get away to get
results versus task 1 dot result after
the task 1 and all has finished yeah
let's put that up there so yeah like
what's the difference do that versus
good Oh waiter it's a little bit more
verbose but that's ok so yeah now the
question is like well what about that
result versus get a waiter get result so
these again will just both do the same
thing like even let's throw all three
examples up here at the same time
because they all will be doing the same
thing actually I'll throw in a fourth
one because we can say it can figure
away false so because that because task
one completed here if task one had
thrown in exception that exception would
have been thrown right here so we never
would have even got to this point and so
we know the results they're waiting for
us because that exception would have
killed our code right here so yeah dot
result dot get away toward it result a
weight and a weight configure away false
these are all doing the same thing but
like I said earlier this one's my
favorite just for that just for that dev
a couple years later so they don't all
of a sudden break the app
great question there they go thank you
sounds good yeah got a little bit more
time looks like about five more minutes
will cue you up next I'm wondering when
you're writing web apps with asp.net do
you always want to configure await false
them oh yeah so do you always want to
configure a false even in say a web app
um already do you have to do it in all
the other lights in the web app to be a
compliant with your suggestion because
you're never touching any you I am right
like what if you're never touching a UI
this is an interesting question so
technically there are certain apps that
don't have that UI thread and those apps
actually won't have a synchronization
context so if you remember the whole
point of the synchronization context is
to remember who called what thread so
that we can go back to it and that's all
literally because of UI stuff so I know
let's see like dotnet core doesn't have
a synchronization contacts so in that
case if you call configure await false
in an app that doesn't have a consent
coordination context it'll just do the
same thing as if you had not called
configure a false because there's
literally nothing there orchestrating
the threads so yeah yeah great point
thanks for bringing that up yeah if we
had another question here in the middle
and oh so yeah my my best advice since
we can't cover everything oh cool we got
another one over here
oh I'm sorry just real quick yeah the
best advice I can give for that question
to just throw that into Google whatever
you're working on like I say like entity
framework doesn't have a synchronization
context and if it doesn't sync then
configure wait false we'll do the same
thing as configure way true or never
using it at all thanks thanks for
bringing that up
if you have multiple calls so one
function calling another one and that
you await in every call do you
figure wait for the first goal or all
the inside goals great question
configure away all the way down
I wish dotnet was smarter let's see
what's a good example let's go let's put
this back to yeah so let's pretend this
code was still like this right
this command kicks off all it's doing is
awaiting this method dot weight or
dotnet isn't smart enough to know that
this is the last line in a method and to
not switch back to the calling thread
when it's done so I know it looks weird
but if we were gonna do something like
that we'd still want to use configure
wait falls even here so even if it's the
last method the last line of the method
dotnet still is gonna bring you back to
the calling thread if we do not use
configure way false so yeah all the way
down unless you're unless you need to
return to the calling thread of course
yeah so when you start going down this
rabbit hole with you should relate to
get to a blog article by Stephen Clare I
think his name was where it says there
is no thread so not necessarily get a
new threat on thread pool if you do Anna
wait oh man so this is yeah this is why
that's what I meant but the rabbit hole
goes deep alright so first thing if
you've never heard of Stephen Cleary
it's spelled Stefan Cleary check him out
he's the de facto expert on a sink and a
weight and he's probably the only person
in the world I would trust not even
myself talking about a sink in a way
like I think I know my stuff and then
yeah I read article from Stephen Cleary
it's like oh I guess I didn't know
anything so yeah that article is called
there is no thread and there's a couple
things going on in there I think
probably the most relevant one cuz I
mean he does get into like some
nitty-gritty technicalities on how disk
IO works and to be honest I just don't
remember everything you said it's a
great article do check it out
but things like this right here so we
just we said task dot run but we never
used the await keyword in here dot Nets
not gonna put that onto a different
thread like if you think back to
remember move next that giant switch
statement
well there's only gonna be one case and
so if thread one calls this thread one's
just gonna fall right through get to the
result and return it and we'll return
the result it never because we never use
the away keyword so yeah there's there's
kind of two parts of that blog and like
I said like one is like the deep deep
stuff on like how disk IO works and why
technically with C code that's still be
on my beyond my capabilities but yeah
the the other big point there is if you
don't use the await keyword inside of a
task dot Nets not gonna put that task on
to a different thread so that's a good
point to make not and because of that
not every task is a threat die just
confuse everybody awesome question
though uh anybody else all right thanks
so much for coming everybody
[Applause]